the top commander of the palestinian
armed group and the al-aqsa brigades has
been killed in a raid by israeli forces
in the occupied west bank ibrahim
nabulsi was known as the lion of nablus
there are reports that others were also
killed in the operation palestinian
authorities say more than 30 people were
wounded
well john holman joins us on the phone
now he's on the road to where this
happened
john what more do we know about the raid
at this point in time
yeah we know that it happened or it
began at around 5 a.m uh so early in the
morning
when israeli forces entered into the
occupied west bank
and they went to the old city in nablus
which is
a sort of a place it's as its name
described it's old and it's got
buildings that are quite close together
they surrounded the building uh in which
uh ibrahim al-nabusi had sort of hold
himself up and then there was a
firefight which according to our
colleagues our producers
in uh in the occupied west bank lasted
for hours and during that time he
refused to surrender and he was defended
by other armed palestinians eventually
the israeli forces the israeli military
uh managed to manage to kill him it's
actually uh unusual that that sort of
raid would happen at that time during
the daylight hours usually they happen
uh in the night time when obviously
there's less civilians
sort of around and as you mentioned uh
there were more than 30 people injured
four of those in a critical condition so
the sort of the result of having this
firefight possibly at this time and in
that crowded uh area um now uh
ibrahimowski
was a commander of the al-aqsa martyrs
brigade which is the military arm of the
fatah uh political movement uh
just for our audience who will obviously
have been following what's been
happening in gaza over the last few days
that's separate from islamic jihad which
is another uh palestinian group of uh
resistance that's operating in the
occupied west bank but also in gaza so
this is a separate this is a separate
sort of attack on a separate uh force
that's in the occupied west bank we also
know as well that this wasn't the first
time that israeli forces had had tried
to get uh ibrahim al-nabul they tried
several times including in july in a
massive operation again in which two
other men died
john holman thank you very much for that
update